elon musk says he will sell 24 billion
dollars a tesla stock if twitter twitter
votes for it while the world's richest
person's
richest people's net worth is reported
in the billions of dollars and can
fluctuate by billions of dollars every
month that value is not liquid unless
they were to sell stocks otherwise known
as unrealized gains currently our tax
code and financial systems are built
around the notion that you haven't made
any money until you sell those stocks
and realize the gains this results in
billionaires sometimes seeing their net
worth increased by billions of dollars
in a year and yet not having to pay any
taxes that your tesla ceo elon musk has
argued against taxing those unrealized
gains which makes sense but he has now
taken it to twitter to offer an
alternative he says that if twitter
votes
for it he will sell 10 of his stake in
tesla which is going to have to pay
taxes on because he owes
he has a 15 billion dollar tax bill
right now according to and uh cnn cnbc
combined the state and federal tax rate
it'll be 54.1 percent so the total tax
on his options at the current price will
be 15 billion dollars if you want to go
to his tweet
actually click on it go to it look at
the results of the poll though what did
they say yes yes so what does this mean
yes so he asked this question yep right
almost 60 40. yep almost 60 58 said yes
i support you selling by the way he said
i will abide by the results of this poll
so what does that mean now is he going
to stay true to his word and actually
sell ten percent i think so i think so
you think he's gonna do that that's why
tesla has been going down the last few
days i mean i think so but i had a
question though on this because i was
looking at it and they said that the um
options uh in the 2012 as a part of the
compensation plan because he doesn't
need a bonus her salary his wealth comes
from stock prices and they said that
they would
the options would expire in august of
next year
does that mean he wouldn't get those
stock options
options that expect
saying here the options expire in august
of next year um yet in order to exercise
them musk has to pay the income tax on
the gain does that mean that he wouldn't
receive them if he doesn't if they
expire would they go back to tesla
stockholders yeah but he would activate
it he would exercise the stocks and he
would buy him yeah so he so he buys them
so for him he has courts basically he
has to do this anyway so it's either do
it now and be a meme king or do it next
but
guess what the move is on doing it this
way guess what the move is on doing now
people want him to do it so when that
comes back public center so this his
strategy on doing it this way is to
prevent the tesla stock of dropping
dramatically so he goes and asks so the
audience says this yeah then he says i
will abide by i'm doing what you asked
me to do i didn't make the decision he
must have known that the audience was
going to vote for you of course he does
there's a part of everyone that's like
do it bro yeah do it yeah especially if
it's like 15 million 10 exactly everyone
15.
how many
how many votes three and a half million
yeah something that you know people
should understand maybe people don't are
familiar with this you could probably
speak to this is the realized versus
unrealized gains he talks about he says
look i do not take a cash salary or
bonus from anywhere i only have stock
thus the only way for me to pay taxes
personally is to sell
stock you know the billionaires became
way richer this year why because of
their stock
in the stock market right so anyway
thoughts on on taxing that's a lot of
talk about we talked about realized
taxing unrealized gains that's crazy
right it's pathetic it's the dumbest
thing they've ever talked about what do
you mean unrealized gains you know how
tough of a situation you're going to put
people into it's going to be insane if
they do something like that just the
fact that they're they're talking about
it makes
zero sense
just break that down why does it make no
sense
because you haven't made money you know
how they say this guy's worth two
billion dollars he's worth two billion
dollars today
pre-tax
after tax he's probably only worth nine
hundred and twenty million dollars
did that make sales you're saying no no
the money is not going to come two
billion dollars is not going to come to
the guy so so for example elon musk says
he's worth what 300 billion dollars what
is elamos really worth
elon musk is really if he sold 100 of
what he owns let's just say the shares
most of it is in stock let's just add a
300 billion dollars he's worth
say 280 is in stocks 20 billion is
something else whatever i'm just
guesstimating the 280 billion he sells
capital gains he's going to pay what on
that 24 20 so
28 on 280 is what 56 56 minus 20 is what
234 224 he's worth 224. that's assuming
the stock doesn't drop another 20
percent tomorrow so and then that's
that's
so to say this guy's worth this much
he's not worth that much
he is not to pay taxes
it's paper right there's there's
difference between cash rich and paper
rich paper rich is what that thing is
worth on that day okay so then you sell
you still have to pay that taxes so it
makes no sense to pay unrealized gains
taxes the government
you know everything that's going on with
the well tax and the billionaires taxes
they're talking there's two people at
the top of their list that they're
looking at and they're getting they're
salivating they're looking at bezos and
they're looking at musk and they're
saying we want a piece of that money
these guys have become dude i did a
uh wrong enemy though you're going after
the wrong person well because they can
afford to fight you
and they're going to hire all the best
cpas lawyers
not about that it's not about that
what's it about
so so let me let me ask a question so
for example for example let's just say
um
you know you you create a uh you create
an incentive program where you make
certain things uh legal whatever take a
drug that you make legal okay
i use the cocaine okay i use cocaine and
all of a sudden i get arrested
hypothetically and i kill myself okay i
chose to do that right okay great but
you made it legal okay you made it legal
for me to get access to it great so
that's the law you made it legal i got
access to it no problem say i'm driving
in an autobahn and the speed limit is
what there is no speed limit in germany
i go 180 miles an hour i hit somebody
that's going 50. okay now you told me
there's no uh restrictions on how fast i
can go maybe you ought to put some
restrictions on that right okay so you
talk about how rich a person got how did
the person become rich did he create the
laws is he the one that's creating the
tax code is he the one that created what
did he do wrong what did he do wrong he
didn't do anything wrong he simply went
out there used the current tax code that
everybody else uses and he made money
for himself that's doing something wrong
oh but he's greedy why don't you go
create 300 billion dollars a network
let's see if you can do it since you
make it look like it's so easy i dare
you to go do a matter of fact let's put
a challenge for you we'll give you 20
years go see if you can be worth 300
billion how many people have done that
you're making it seem like this is a sin
on what these guys are doing stop it
warren buffett is worth 100 some billion
dollars
what do you who do you know that stay
disciplined in one industry for 60 plus
years 70 plus years you should reward
that there should be an incentive and
rewarding of that so demonizing these
guys is the dumbest thing to do out
there by constantly demonizing what
these guys are doing speaking of buffett
you know he's been very vocal that he
thinks he should pay more taxes why do
you think he says that i'm asking you
why do you think he says that though
pandering why do you think he says that
maybe a a maybe he does feel like he
should pay more taxes okay then do go
ahead nobody's forcing you not to do it
go do it a lot of it is he's being he's
choosing no no
when people say with a giving point when
people say stuff like that
nobody stopped you from sending more tax
money in go send it he could write a
check
go for it iris is going to keep that
money keep saying that
okay so
my god you can't be that naive at him
this is the part that sometimes i wonder
and i sit and i say this guy's adam's a
level of naivete
why don't we unpack that sure why don't
we unpack that have you ever read
buffett's uh books no what is it called
snowball effects snowball you ever read
his book you ever read his material i've
read i've read some stuff that he's
written a shareholder every year have
you read uh his relationship with
politics over the years how close he
realized he needed to get to
political people and to understand the
fact that politics are involved and what
he wants to do have you ever studied
okay so
so
how how valuable is it
to
an obama
to get a buffet to say i should pay more
taxes how much
does a
buffett
saying that
in an interview with cnbc or fox
business or cnn or abc or nbc
a week after obama announces raising of
taxes for buffett to say i should pay
more taxes how much does that get the
average person to say exactly what you
just said which is what
well buffett said they should raise my
taxes and maybe it should be okay why
are you not okay with you raising your
taxes he's worth 50 billion at the time
you're not you should be okay if he's
okay it's not how this stuff works the
way these things work is hey what would
you like me to do hey listen here's what
i like to see
i'm having a hard time with xyz we like
to be able to do this i like to see the
administration follow and pass in the
following whatever law whatever
you know policy etc etc great hey can
you do me a favor yeah do you mind going
out there and supporting my tax bill and
saying the fact that people like you
should pay more taxes
yeah i'll do that okay how soon can you
do that do you mind doing it tomorrow
can you call one to press conferences or
can you call one of these guys and write
that up sure the next day boom and then
obama goes up and says listen folks a
lot of people complain about taxes but
here's the thing how many guys are
richer than buffett if warren buffett
says he should pay more taxes maybe you
ought to be okay with it as well because
this thing doesn't hurt anybody else
more than it hurts warren buffett boom
you know what he's right boom the bill
gets passed now do i know 100 this
happened or not of course i don't know
the 100 whether this happened or not but
when you make it to that level of wealth
you don't give a about taxes you
give a about regulation it ain't
taxes it's regulation you care about you
don't sit there and say i'd love to save
another 2 in capital gains no no
you'd love to create a new regulation or
deregulate something to help you take
your business to the next level or
eliminate competition that's what's
that's what you're more interested in at
that level again this is speculation if
i'm wrong believe i'm wrong which which
direction you think buffett votes
i think buffett uh has voted i know
buffett's voted left and right
throughout his career
uh he's not somebody that's voted only
on the left or only on the right he's
gone both sides but i think uh again
adam i think it changes on how you vote
at that time you're not just voting at
that time based on
uh uh uh
the same thing that an average person
votes fit
votes with at that time you're voting on
who you think you can get the most
things done with because you're warren
buffett
so if you vote for a person that wants
to have nothing to do with you you're
going to get done with that person
so you'd much rather get somebody to get
elected that's willing to work with you
during those four years to help pass
stuff that's going to favor you do you
think you voted for trump ever
i don't know
i don't think voter trump went with
buffett i don't think you voted for
trump no i don't think because i don't
think he's sure he endorsed i don't
think a buffett likes people like trump
because it's not his cup of tea
i don't think buffett is a trump guy
and i don't think trump's a buffett guy
i don't think uh i don't see those two
having dinner together the whole reason
that i brought that up is because
obviously you're talking about taxes and
why
uh
in this case elon musk was not willing
to obviously want to pay more taxes
but essentially
you have a buffet saying yes we should
pay more and you have a musk
saying that no i should pay less so
here's my point
they're both concerned about regulation
are they not let me ask you questions
let me ask you a question yeah let me
ask you a question between the two you
ready here's a question for you okay
which one of the two does the current
administration like and support
the current administration does not uh
for so for whatever reason get along
with elon why do you think they don't
like elon musk i don't know but he
hasn't been invited to any of the well
why do you think why do you think though
why do you think though
why
because he's questioning their their
antics why
because he's a guy he's one no the
people the people who have voted for
biden are also the people that are
trying to get rid of him in terms of
like the car manufacturers the other
companies and stuff like that
and
elon musk because he calls out under
they cannot stand a guy like elon musk
they cannot stand a guy like him he's a
troublemaker he cause he he shakes and
shakes the system but but he also gets
results so listen there's troublemakers
that don't know
trump he can understand him and see him
for what he is and be like oh he's elon
musk he's innovation like there's a
there's the risk there's the annoyance
with the reward in terms of progress but
with the with the people that are very
structured and very like proper
let me ask you who's more scared bezos
or elon musk
scared who's more scared of what of the
administration who was more scared i
think uh elon musk no i think jeff bezos
by far but not even close
how how how would you say amazon the way
they're going after amazon the way that
there's more of a monopoly there and i
also think that elon musk is more kind
of like i don't give a type of guy
okay let me ask a question in a
completely different way from you here's
a different way of asking a question
from you you ready
you know the movie gladiator where
russell crowe goes up to
his owner and he says hey you used to be
a
gladiator right now
when the crowd okay you think bezos has
won the crowd no you think elon musk has
won the crowd absolutely matter of fact
pull up jeff bezos's twitter account i
don't even know the number i want to say
six million i'm gonna say seven i don't
know the number i wanna say six or seven
million for a guy worth two hundred
billion dollars he's only got six or
seven million followers i was off
three million okay now go to elon musk
okay
net worth about the same used to be six
months ago three months ago unless
things change too
until things change in the last two
weeks just click on elon musk right
there
go back click on illness on his account
63 million
that's 21 times
21 times more so you have to know elon
has won the crowd bezos has not
so elon if you go after elon you're
going after 63 million people that are
going to come after they're going to
rally behind if you go after bezos
no one's going to be they're going to be
like listen it is what it is
bezos is scared elon musk is not scared
bezos how often have you heard bezos
ruffle the feathers of people in
politics and say something all the time
no bezos oh oh basic never no how long
how is it
the only time the only time i think i've
seen that is when he's yeah when he's
like everyone's everyone's agreeing with
that but it's popular it's popular it's
more hopping on it because you know the
odds are it's an easy it's an easy win
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]